when I went to the preview screening of
happy deathday director Christopher
Landon offered some insight about the
sequel in a Q&A if you want to hear
about that then stick around to the end
of this video happy deathday was one of
the better surprises of 2017 no pun
intended what appeared to be a generic
slasher actually ended up being a pretty
decent mystery that kind of threw me for
a loop pun only slightly intended it was
definitely more than just Groundhog Day
gone horn but with the announcement of
the sequel happy death day to you the
question becomes can they do it again
let's start by looking at what we know
about the new film the first movie took
place on Theresa's birthday and she had
to keep reliving it until she solved the
puzzle the addition of the two you to
the title could be a continuation of the
song that goes happy birthday to you but
I think of this sequel we'll have tree
reliving a different day on the calendar
happy death day to you is scheduled to
release on Valentine's Day 2019 the to
you in the title is stylized like the
text on one of those candy hearts but
the messages on them that you see around
Valentine's Day so I think this movie
takes place four months later on
February 14th which is actually
horrifying I cannot think of a worse day
to be trapped in it to have to relive
over and over if you saw my initial
things you missed on the happy deathday
trailer last year you'll know that I was
disappointed that the song happy
deathday by Alien Ant Farm did not end
up in the movie well this time they
literally have no excuse not to the
lyrics literally have the title of the
movie row it
[Music]
I'm not talking about just having a
license song in the trailer but not the
movie we're not falling for that again
come on jason blum I know you're
watching this I know you're here to
false copyright claim this video so you
can squeeze those precious pennies out
of me before I file a dispute but while
you're here let's make this song thing
happen or at the very least to get
Dethklok in there
[Music]
[Music]
but yeah as I mentioned earlier the
director of happy deathday Christopher
Landon did a Q&A at a preview screening
that I attended last year where he was
asked about a possible sequel keep in
mind this was before happy deathday had
to come out and pull the hundred 20ml at
the box office and he said that he
already had a sequel in mind that alone
should give you some hope that it will
be decent because that shows me that the
sequel is story motivated and not just
money motivated
he also deflected questions about the
cause of the time loop and hinted that
we could get more info about why it
takes place in a sequel one of the
things that made the first movie work
was that it didn't try to over explain
things and instead focused on character
relationships and growth if the sequel
can replicate that while introducing
more information about the setting and
concept I think we'll have a repeat
success pun intended if you haven't seen
my things you missed on happy deathday
and be sure to click on the video on the
left to watch that and if you'd like to
see me do with things you missed on
happy deathday to you then leave a like
on this video to let me know remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds from new
Horrors every week bring that death belt
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive